ja und zu uns ist jetzt frau sanja
flaßpöhler gestoßen sie ist philosophin
und chefredaktorin des philosophie
magazins in berlin frau flaßpöhler wenn
sie sich das jetzt angehört haben sie
hätten die wahl zwischen lsd sauber
pilzen base jumping oder extrem klettern
oder nüchtern was wenn sie wählen
naja nüchtern kenne ich ja und ich bin
würde ich sagen schon ein neugieriger
mensch
deshalb würde ich mich eher für die
anderen optionen entscheiden aber wenn
ich zwischen denen wählen müsste würde
ich wahrscheinlich am ehesten das
klettern nehmen weil mich tatsächlich am
rausch glaube ich also dass ich bin
glaube ich eher der typ der tatsächlich
noch kontrolle behalten will und ich
glaube dass das fand ich jetzt sehr
interessant also der gipfel spielt eine
rolle aber noch wichtiger ist es wieder
nach hause zu kommen und das ist eben
eine beständige beständiges tätig sein
und eine beständige arbeit die es
ermöglicht diesen rausch zu erfahren
aber trotzdem bei sich zu bleiben
wir haben im vorfeld aber auch darüber
gesprochen dass genau das auch die
schwierigkeit ist dass man im rausch
diese ambivalenz ab einerseits wollen
wir dieses total unkontrollierte die
ekstase und hingehen dahinfließen und
andererseits aber bitte dann doch wieder
heil nach hause kommen
ist das nicht ein widerspruch ich glaube
da müsste man jetzt sehr genau denke ich
darüber reden was über was für ein
rausreden wer eigentlich und ich glaube
der der rausch im engeren sinne also der
rausch der durch alkohol entsteht durch
durch drogen entsteht das würde ich
sagen ist schon ein rausch wo es eben
gerade um den selbstverlust geht oder
die selbst die totale
selbstvergessenheit geht und auch den
kontrollverlust geht in gewisser weise
und das macht es natürlich so gefährlich
und das ist eben auch die nähe des
rausches zum tod und deshalb hat die
kultur ja eben ein sehr ambivalentes
verhältnis zum rausch auf der einen
seite sind wir als kulturwesen als
gesellschafts wesen angehalten bestimmte
grenzen ein
zu halten wir sind leistungs subjekte
wir müssen arbeiten wir können morgens
nicht mit dem kater aufwachen usw und
gleichzeitig stellt uns die kultur aber
ja schon auch möglichkeiten immer schon
bereit so ein bisschen ich sag mal so
ein bisschen triebabfuhr zu leisten
ein bisschen loszulassen grenzen zu
überschreiten und insofern kann man
sagen ist auch eine kulturtechnik finden
sie sich in dieser beschreibung wieder
triebabfuhr und und ihre angebote lsd
trips und ich würde jetzt die arbeit die
wir machen nicht unbedingt in einem
psychoanalytisch framework präsentieren
wir haben heute neue wissenschaftliche
theorien auch biologische theorien wie
wir uns versuchen zu erklären was hier
eigentlich genau passiert habe ich denke
ambivalenz zwischen gutes stichwort oder
das geht einerseits um eben dieses
gefühl von ozeanische selbst entgrenzung
von flow von abenteuerlust was auch sehr
eng mit unserem dopamin system im gehirn
gekoppelt ist und letztlich auch die
menschliche evolution vorangebracht hat
also wären wir heute ohne diesen antrieb
da ist natürlich viel neugier drehen
oder entdeckerlust ich denke sowohl
sportler wie auch wissenschaftler oder
künstler begeben sich in diese
rauschhaften zustände wo sie dann zu
höchstleistungen letztlich fähig sind
und so eigentlich einen beitrag leisten
oder auch zur installation
das ist jetzt ein sehr positives bild
vom rausch der ausstellungs letztlich
dazu treibt extrem leistungen zu
vollbringen vielleicht auch das extreme
zu ersehnen wie geht es ihnen die
zuhören hält er navi weiß ja immer auch
die gefahr des rausches sozusagen
miterlebt haben also ich würde beides
ich finde das ist sehr distanziert in
beide richtungen
also ich persönlich würde das drama hast
im rauschen im sinn von gerade wenn man
die kunstlandschaft jeder kunstschüler
denkt die großen künstler haben drogen
genommen haben da ihre größte leistung
erbracht ich muss das auch und da wird
eine qualität hergestellt die eigentlich
eine korrelation ist also viele künstler
hatten auf ihn zu drogen aber nicht
jeder der drogen genommen hat ist ein
großer künstler geworden und bei diesen
gesellschaftlichen aspekt da drogen
würde ich es als schmiermittel also ich
könnte mir keine gesellschaft ohne
rausch vorstellen so schon ohne alkohol
war für mich unvorstellbar weil viele
leute diesen teil an ventil oder diesen
teil von 1 themen benötigen um in einer
sozialen strukturen wie wir sie heute
haben überhaupt funktionieren zu können
über die gesellschaft wird sich später
gerne noch einmal sprechen
bleiben die vielleicht noch einmal kurz
auch bei der wirkung warum wir diese
substanzen zu uns nehmen waren das
fasziniert hat nicht daran und ein
begriff könnte ja dieses psychedelische
sein also das ist ein griechischer
begriff wenn man den übersetzt heißt das
bewusstseinserweiternd was wird denn da
genau erweitert herrschte kein welche
richtung erweitert also einerseits werde
natürlich wahrnehmungen vertieft
intensiviert gefühle kommen hoch das
denken vielleicht nicht mehr in den
gewohnten bahnen bei höheren dosen kann
sein dass ich auch das körpergefühl
beginnt aufzulösen
das auch zeit und raum eigentlich nicht
mehr in der gewohnten art existieren und
die grenzen zwischen ich und umwelt
verschmelzen so dass das individuum sich
eigentlich als teil eines größeren
ganzen erlebt das kann sehr positiv
erlebt werden aber wenn die person auch
widerstände hat oder ängste hat sich so
gehen zu lassen kann das auch sehr
angstvoll sein und das sind dann oft die
schlaufen die dann letztlich auch in
einen trip minden können aus
philosophischer sicht muss das ja
interessant sein für sie weil
grundsätzlich kann man sagen philosophie
hat sich immer interessiert für
erkenntnis immer interessiert dafür mit
dem bewusstsein weiter zu kommen also
suchen sie vielleicht mal eine session
ja ich weiß auch nicht also ich bin ich
muss wirklich sagen ich bin mit bier
sozialisiert also bier kenne ich mit
bier kann ich umgehen
ich habe noch sei aber jetzt nicht so
bewusstseinserweiternd oder doch wo das
würde ich so nicht sagen aber ich muss
sagen ich hab' ich habe tatsächlich auch
berührungsängste
also was was eben solche drogen angeht
wahrscheinlich hängt es auch sehr stark
davon ab was man sozialisiert wurde er
dass ich einfach nie berührung damit
hatte und jetzt für mich nicht sicher
nicht so richtig klar wird warum soll
ich das jetzt nehmen sie sagen
bewusstseinserweiterung ja das stimmt
gleichzeitig hätte ich aber tatsächlich
immer die sorge dass da etwas mit meinem
geist mit meinem gehirn passiert dass
ich nicht mehr unter kontrolle habe dass
ich nicht mehr beeinflussen kann
bestimmt stecken da gibt's ja bestimmt
steckt da auch so ein bisschen so eine
authentizität stick bei mir drin dass
ich also ich habe zum beispiel schon
große probleme überhaupt eine
kopfschmerztablette zu nehmen weil ich
das gefühl habe okay ich hab jetzt
kopfschmerzen da muss ich jetzt durch
das wären so das ist echt ich habe
kopfschmerzen
da frage ich mich warum habe ich die
jetzt strengt mich irgendetwas zu sehr
an also schmerzen sind ja auch eine
weise sich selbst zu erkennen oder
bestimmte situationen zu analysieren
vielleicht sein leben zu ändern deshalb
sehr empfohlen die psychoanalyse erwähnt
ich bin eben auch psychoanalyse
sozialisiert ich habe eine psychoanalyse
gemacht sehr lange und ich glaube diese
dieser arbeit an sich selbst die eben
auch bewusstseinserweiterung erweitert
sein kann
total bewusstseinserweiternd aber für
mich gehört die arbeit am selbst
eigentlich immer dazu weil er weichen
weil ich dabei bin und vielleicht ist
hat das auch was protestantisches weiß
ich nicht ich bin gar nicht
protestantisch aber manchmal denke ich
ich wäre es
also insofern habe ich da wirklich ich
habe da sehen muss man respekt davor
finden sie dann
ich sehe also dass
bewusstseinserweiternde das gab das
gefühl vom 1 1 mit an
ich habe bei mir und bei anderen leuten
die ich kenne die in den psychedelic
unterwegs waren
eigentlich erlebt dass ein sehr
egozentrische ort ist also die
wahrnehmung wird verändert vielleicht
sogar die bewusstseins abläufe werden
verändert hat die realität bleibt sich
gleich also wenn ich mit freunden
unterwegs war auf seelischen drogen war
jeder auf seinem eigenen planet und ich
hatte zwar schon das gefühl ich sei mit
allen anderen verbunden hat aber
effektiv für mich danach nicht mehr
gestorben weil es auch wirklich nicht so
wahr ich war auf meinem eigenen planeten
in meiner eigenen realität und das hat
bei mir am ende ebenso ein gewisses
gefühl von einsamkeit ausgelöst nachdem
raus ja also ich denke der rauch ist das
eine
und der alltag ist das andere und wie
schaffen wir da quasi eine
querverbindung herzustellen
psychedelische substanzen können
natürlich auch uns in illusionen oder
den falsche wahrheiten treiben was mich
als psychotherapeut interessiert ist
quasi mit jedem patienten oder mit jedem
menschen der so eine erfahrung gemacht
hat letztlich sich zu fragen was aus
dieser erfahrung kannst du mitnehmen und
in sein leben integrieren und ich denke
ohne diese arbeit verblasst das relativ
schnell im universum
ich würde gerne noch einmal auf diese
frage des authentischen zurückkommen auf
das echte weil wir wahrscheinlich alle
die man gläschen wein getrunken haben
wissen dass in dem moment vielleicht
unglaublich geniale ideen haben und am
tag darauf dann wieder an die notizen
lesen merken ja ja so genial ausgleich
doch nicht und dann fragt man sich das
war eigentlich echt daran und wir merken
wir haben uns das vielleicht ein
bisschen eingebildet die großartige
künstlerische bewegung dina gerade
durchgemacht hat
und in diesem zusammenhang kann man sich
ja wirklich fragen was ist eigentlich
das echte in so einem rauschzustand
und ich glaube man muss im moment über
tc boyles neuesten roman sprechen das
licht weil er da drin im grunde genommen
timo viel iris geschichte nacherzählt
der harvard professor für psychologie
der der vater der gugl bewegung war und
mit lsd ganz viel experimentiert hat und
wer sagt das ist wirklich eine
neuprogrammierung des gehirns und es
geht letztendlich darum wirklich das
gehirn so zu strukturieren dass wir ganz
neu zu sehen lernen
aber was sehen wir denn da ist das
einbildung oder realität
oder ist die frage schon falsch und
demaskiert nicht auf eine person die
keine ahnung habt sie lachen so nett
sehr schade für mich als förster sind
diese substanz natürlich faszinierende
tools oder um einblicke zu gewinnen wie
unser gehirn eigentliche realität
hervorbringt also wir können ziemlich
alle dimensionen unseres realität sind
in verschiedene himmelsrichtungen
erweitern und studieren was da nicht
passiert und ich glaube ich würde nicht
sagen die substanzen implizieren eine
absolute realität oder etwas woran man
zu glauben hat sondern sie können uns
vielleicht etwas darüber lehrern wie
realität sind entsteht quasi in den
maschinenraum des bewusstseins
reinzuschauen und die verschiedenen
elemente da bin ich zu erkennen die
zudem beitragen was letztlich realität
ist vielleicht machen wir noch ein strom
zu diesen sogenannten micro 1000 das
kann ganz am anfang im einspieler auch
bereits vor das sind klein stossen am
lsd im moment wird sehr viel darüber
diskutiert scheint auch in der schweiz
mehr und mehr verbreitet zu sein
vor allem im silicon valley ein enormer
trends das heißt menschen nehmen
kleinste dosen von lsd und zwar nicht
mehr mit dem ziel auf den trip zu gehen
uns irgendwelche
bewusstseinserweiternden geschichten da
ab zu feiern sondern um in erster linie
produktiver kreativer leistungs
bewusster zu werden
ja das ist eigentlich kann man sagen die
die perversion des genießens also die
umdrehung weil das genießen eigentlich
wenn man's kulturgeschichtlich
betrachtet ist es eben immer eher an die
grenzüberschreitung gekoppelt also ich
überschreite die grenze des leistungs
imperativ des trieb verzichts also all
das was wir was wir tagtäglich leisten
müssen ohne dass wir so richtig merken
aber als kulturwesen machen wir das
eigentlich minütlich dauernd und das
genießen überschreitet genau diese renz
und daraus resultiert auch die lust also
das kann man wirklich in der
philosophiegeschichte von sad über
georges partei sehr schöner verfolgen
das ist immer eigentlich diese die lust
an der grenzüberschreitung ist und
daneben die lust gerade nicht produktiv
zu sein also all diese diese
gesetzmäßigkeiten unseres alltags
wirklich auszuhebeln und in dem man
jetzt aber sagt man man nimmt den genuss
in kleinen dosen um die produktivität
anzugucken dass ich meine es jetzt noch
gar nicht wertend aber es ist erst mal
ganz deskriptive beschreibend gesagt
eine perversion eine umdrehung der logik
sehen sie das auch so aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht wäre ich da
jetzt relativ zurückhaltend was das
marketing betrifft ich denke wir wissen
noch gar nicht genau was genau macht und
es
wir haben zwar viele erfahrungsberichte
im internet aber letztlich wissen wir
noch nicht ob das letztlich auf eine
mine bildungs effekt oder einem placebo
effekt beruht weil die personen sich
vielleicht suggerieren ihre ressourcen
besser nutzen zu können indem sie
täglich irgend so eine kleine menge
einer substanz zu führen aber rein
pharmakologisch würde ich sagen war es
denkbar dass microsoft effekte hat wir
wissen es einfach
sie schmunzeln ja ich kenne leute die
gerade unter großem stress makellosen
gemacht haben
in kreativen berufen oder das was man
heute kreativer beruf das war witzig
weil wenn man diese leute war oder zwei
begleitet hat in der arbeit hat man
gemerkt ihre arbeit wurde nicht besser
nicht schneller nicht kreativer nicht
überraschende aber sie waren eher
zufrieden damit was ja auch ein schöner
effekt ist wunderbar aber das habe ich
vorher gemacht mit der egozentrik mann
verwendung nur begrenzt die äußere
realität aber man kann durchaus die
eigene einstellung dazu zu verwenden und
über einem jahr oder zwei kann es dazu
kommen dass die eigene zufriedenheit mit
der arbeit dazu führt dass man dann
wirklich jahren kreativer kreativen
zugang zu den sachen krieg das hat aber
ein bisschen mit diesem placebo effekt
zu tun und es hat natürlich wie bei für
beim kokain die in der in der arbeit
damit zu tun dass man das gefühl hat man
tut etwas um die kontrolle zu behalten
und in unserer arbeitswelt ist eine
substanz nehmen oder den leuten man kann
den leuten wahrscheinlich auch
hustensaft geben und sagen das gibt dir
die kontrolle über deine kreativität
kann schon hilfsmittel sein und dann
über zeit wirklich kreative zu sein aber
ich glaube der punkt auf den flaßpöhler
hinaus wollte den würde ich doch gerne
auch mal aufnehmen der ist schon wichtig
zu sehen wenn man dieses buch von dalís
dann begegnet man einer hippie welt die
leute sind splitternackt nehmen lsd und
rennen durchs gras und fühlen sich die
tiere oder
käfer oder was weiß ich alles
währenddessen heute mehr die idee ist
vielleicht man nimmt sowohl dosiert
kleine dosen um ein bisschen kreativ zu
sein am computer oder man geht auf den
begleiteten trip macht das ein mal im
jahr und therapeutischen nutzen zu haben
ich über spezielle extras ein bisschen
aber wo bleibt eigentlich der
dionysischen rausch den nietzsche noch
besungen hat gibt es dennoch
das hat sich geändert seit den 90ern
heute arbeitet man fünf tage und aus
sich ins system ein und leistet und
freitagabends geht's los das kann dann
pillen seien das kann alkohol sein dann
kann man loslassen und sich quasi
erholen um dann montags wieder dort sein
insofern ist es micro singh eine andere
form von diesem wochenende lief das
heißt ich habe in jeden tag ein bisschen
was anstatt jedes wochenende den
totalabsturz den totalabsturz
ja ich finde sie beschreiben noch eine
arbeitswelt die glaube ich so gar nicht
mehr existiert also etwas was ich immer
mehr erlebe es eigentlich die
entgrenzung der arbeitswelt also auch
ins wochenende hinein also gerade
natürlich durch die die durch die
digitalisierung also betreffen wir
tragen ja alle unsere produktionsmittel
quasi in der tasche unserer
arbeitsmittel und was ich da sehe ich
eher sagen würde ist dass die arbeit zum
rausch wird und zum genuss wird und
zurück zum ex es sogar also es gibt ja
die arbeitssucht workaholic und dass der
genuss umgekehrt eigentlich immer mehr
zur arbeit wird also dass man den leuten
fast sagen muss jetzt genießt doch mal
jetzt entspannt euch doch mal und das
ich glaube dass es die problematik ist
die immer mehr leute haben gar nicht so
sehr dass sie irgendwie abhängig sind
oder den rausgehen das gibt es natürlich
auch aber ich kenne viele leute und dazu
würde ich mich sogar auch wahrscheinlich
sogar erzählen also die leute die eher
probleme haben mal loszulassen